good morning Hank good morning Hank good
morning Hank good morning Hank I wonder
if I've said anything in my life
anyway it's Monday I hope you enjoied
Venice Florida as much as I enjoyed
Venice Italy I was there because the
Indianapolis Museum of Art where the
Yeti is a curator commissioned the 2011
American Pavillion of the Venice
Biennale which is a really fancy deal
for example not to brag I went to a
party with Michael Stipe the lead singer
of REM who wrote the songs stand which
you and I choreographed a dance to in
1989 which our dad videotaped and then
blessedly lost the artist the IMA
Commissioner called awara and kel cydia
and the pavilion is a total success it
involves overturn tanks and Olympic
decathlete sand gymnasts and an actual
ATM machine that is also an actual pipe
organ hey this is the first time the
Commission for the Venice Biennale has
gone to a museum that isn't on either
coast or the Art Institute of Chicago
and I'm really proud of everybody at the
Indianapolis Museum of Art for making it
such a huge success it makes me super
happy to be an Indianapolis Ian or
Indianapolis assist or Indianapolis
Indiana delicious hey where are you from
Oh me I'm Indianapolis in other news
Hank this is my book it arrived today
from New York where my editor and
publisher Julie Strauss Gables sent it
to me you know with all of her comments
on the pages and everything I'm very
excited Hank because even though Julie
and I have been revising this book for
more than a year we've finally reached
the point where she like writes on the
manuscript and we can do the fun stuff
like fighting about how to spilled a
word Stormtrooper and she can write
little notes making fun of me like about
how in my fictional universe every day
is Friday this is a big problem with my
writing I go off and write like on
Friday and Gustus waters called me three
days later on Friday we went out to
lunch and you is just like are you even
trying are you even trying to figure out
what day it should be and I'm like no
I'm not trying that's your job but in
fact well that's the public's perception
of what an editor does the truth is
somewhat more complicated as usual the
real heart of the editorial process
happens way before we ever start
fighting about whether storm troopers is
one word or two and whether every day
can be Friday it starts when I send
Julia Draft and then she sends me an
editorial letter and that editorial
letter isn't about comma splices it
includes sentences like as we crackle
because this is philosophy and contrast
it with Hazel's more connected sense of
living I also think there's a lot of
room to look more at the question of the
nobility and frankly the epic sexiness
of sacrifice slash violence versus the
unsung struggle of illness in short what
constitutes martyrdom as you can see
Hank that's not about spelling by the
way Julie if you're watching this I am
not changing my spelling of
Stormtroopers unless and until George
Lucas himself calls me and tells me that
it's two words that said you're right
about everything else and no matter how
happy it would make Rebecca black I
agree with you that every day should not
be Friday so I think the assumption that
editors exist primarily to like fix
grammar errors is really incorrect I
mean I could just read the University of
Chicago style manual I don't need Julie
for that but I also think it's incorrect
when people think that the main reason
editors exist is to like censor your
work or to somehow make it works without
Julie paper towns would be devoted
largely not to Walt Whitman's poem song
of myself' but to an incredibly boring
history of the machinations of the
United States Postal Service and without
Julie instead of Colin and Tucson
hunting for fewer hogs in rural
Tennessee there would be this 75 page
and I'm not making this up how-to guide
about how to take a road killed raccoon
skin it and then Tana tide I don't know
what I was thinking Hank but back in
2005 I was really interested in hide
tanning and without Julie and before her
my amazing mentor and first editor Ilene
Cooper nothing that anyone likes about
Looking for Alaska would be in that book
in short Hank while God knows I'd like
to think that writers are more important
than editors the truth is that we may
not be I mean there's a reason that the
Great Gatsby and the Sun Also Rises were
edited by the same guy Hank I'm gonna
get to work I'll see you on Friday uh I
didn't do that on purpose and a promise
oh it's like I have kalindra Cleese
Pacific dementia